AND THAT HAS THE CONTRIBUTION OF
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON THE
SHOW.
LAST WEEK TUCKER REPORTED ON THE
LIBERALS HAVE RUN OUT OF RACISTS
STATUES TO TAKE DOWN, SO THEY
HAVE NOW MOVED ON TO RACIST
TREES.
IN THE CALIFORNIA DESERT, THE
CITY OF PALM SPRINGS WANTS TO
IF YOU ARE THINKING, AREN'T
LIBERALS SUPPOSED TO BE TREE
HUGGERS, WELL, YES UNLESS YOU
ARE PLANTING A RACIST TREE.
THE CITY BELIEVES THAT THESE
TREES WERE PLANTED WITH RACIST
INTENT.
OTHERS SAY THAT IT WAS TO
PREVENT PEOPLE CHIPPING THAT
GOLF BALL STRAIGHT THROUGH YOUR
WINDOW.
BUT THAT IS ALWAYS THE COVER FOR
RACISM, ISN'T IT?
>> PEOPLE DON'T GO OUT AND SAY
THAT WE ARE DOING THIS FOR
RACIST REASONS, THEY SAY, WE ARE
GOING TO DO LANDSCAPING, WE ARE
GOING TO LANDSCAPE YOU RIGHT OUT
BALLS.
>> Mark: JUST LIKE RACE, GOLF
BALLS FLYING THROUGH YOUR
KITCHEN WINDOW IS A SOCIAL
THAT'S HUMORIST IS NOW THE
ROBERT E. LEE OF TREES.
IT IS ROBERT E TREE.
AND LIBERALS SUDDENLY HAVE NO
DESIRE TO HUG THAT TREE THAN
THEY DO CHARLIE ROSE OR MATT
LAUER.
AT THE TAM ARREST IS NOT JUST
RACIST, IT IS NASTY.
>> THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN, THE
BLACK FAMILIES WHO PROPERTIES
ARE ADJACENT TO THOSE TREES, IF
YOU HAD DONE ANY RESEARCH ON THE
TREE, YOU KNOW THAT THAT IS ONE
OF THE NASTIEST TREES AROUND AND
ALSO BEEN DECLARED AN
ENVIRONMENTAL DISASTER BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
HOLD ON, BECAUSE THAT TREE IS A
FOREIGN TREE, YOU ARE CALLING IT
TENACITY?
>> Mark: SO TO INVERT BARBARA
WALTERS, IF THIS TREE WERE A
CELEBRITY, WHAT CELEBRITY WOULD
IMMIGRANT CAN GET A DRIVER'S
LICENSE, FREE HEALTH CARE, AND
AN UNLAWFUL IMMIGRANT CAN
PRACTICE LAW IN CALIFORNIA.
THE ONE THING YOU CANNOT DO IS
STAND ON THE EDGE OF A GOLF
>> OKAY, SO ARE YOU A NATIVIST
NOW?
>> WHEN IT COMES TO VEGETATION,
ABSOLUTELY.
YOU CAN LIFT THE TREES AND HAVE
A PROBLEM OF THEM TIPPING OVER
IN THE STORM.
>> Mark: LIBERALS ARE IN FAVOR
OF OPEN BORDERS FOR PEOPLE, BUT
MUSLIM WORLD, BUT THIS IS ONE
HEAD JABS, YOUR SHARIA LAW, BUT
YOU BETTER LEAVE HERE TAMARISK
NOT IN TIMOROUS STICK STAND.
YOU CAN HAVE YOUR CHOICE OF
FEMALE HEAD COVER, BUT NOT TREE
YOUNG MEN OF AN EXTREMIST
PERSUASION, IT IS PRONE TO SELF
COMBUST.
>> THE TREES THEMSELVES HAVE
HAPPENING, SO NOT ONLY DO WE
HAVE THE ASPECT OF THE
TRADITIONAL ORIGIN OF THE
TRADITION BEING TO SEPARATE THE
BLACK AND PEOPLE OF COLOR AROUND
THE STREET, AFTER THEIR HOMES
WERE RUINED BY THE CITY OF
PALM SPRINGS UNDER RACIST
CONSIDERATIONS.
>> Mark: JUST LIKE A KLANSMAN,
THE TAMARISK STANDS UNDER LAW
TAMARISK, OH TAMARISK, HOW
RACIST ARE THOSE BRANCHES.
WHAT CAN WE REPLACE THE TAMARISK
WITH?
YOUR GUESTS TONIGHT IS SAYING NO
>> Mark: >> Mark: DEMOCRS
>> Mark: >> Mark: DEMOCRA
>> Mark: >> Mark: DEMOCRY
>> Mark: >> Mark: DEMOCRR
>> Mark: >> Mark: DEMOCRA
AGO, MORE TREES, LESS BUSH, MORE
TREES, LESS OPEN SPACE TO KEEP
AN EYE ON HARVEY WEINSTEIN AND
KEVIN SPACE B.
YOU THINK THAT LIBERALS HAVE
FLOWN THE COOP, THEY ARE
IF THIS REALLY IS THE ROOT
CAUSE?
WHAT IF TREES ARE RACIST?
HERE ARE THE THREE MOST FORESTED
STATES IN THE UNION.
AND HERE ARE THE WIDEST STATES
IN THE UNION.